statement from wide receiver Josh Gordon
who as we all know spent some time away
from the NFL got reinstated after he was
essentially kicked out there's no other
way to put it he's suspended and came
back reinstated and looked looked as
healthy as an ox is anybody out there
he's his physical Awad receiver as there
is when he is when he is ready and
mentally healthy as well as physically
healthy and he sent out a statement
today to let everybody know that quote
unquote I'm not only doing great
physically but mentally as well you'll
notice that I will not be in Cleveland
for the start of training camp which is
coming up on Wednesday for the Browns at
Berea Ohio rest assured that this too is
part of my overall health and treatment
plan
I appreciate the awesome support mention
that I'm excited to start the season I
have every intention of being ready and
available to enjoy to join my teammates
soon to help bring winning football to
our fans with the help of the NFL and if
I'll play PA the Players Association the
Browns organization I've been able to
utilize the resources available to me
that will ensure my well-being on and
off the field by continuing to follow
the plan set up by our medical director
and his team and taking this time before
the season starts we believe it will
help me maintain the progress I've made
for not only today but for many years to
come thank you all for your patience
love and support go brown sincerely Josh
Gordon the Browns then sent out a
statement from John Dorsey the general
manager we will continue to support Josh
as he receives the care needed to
maintain his progress we're gonna
respect his privacy while he is away
from the team Josh will be placed on the
non football illness reserve list until
he is ready to return and before we get
to Mary Kay Cabot at Cleveland comm I
just want to say again that he is in
stage three of the NFL player the NFL
substance abuse program which means a
player in stage three can be tested up
to ten times per month and a medical
director can order treatment a positive
test or failure to comply triggers
indefinite banishment of at least one
year the league Brian McCarthy saying
quote unquote absolutely not suspended
so perhaps it's a medical director as he
mentioned saying let's take a break
maybe you need a few weeks don't go to
training camp wait a couple weeks team
says they want to give him some some
space now while hoping that he does get
the space he needs
we still need to wonder what's going on
best we can
Mary Kate Cabot back here in the Rich
Eisen show how are you Mary Kate I'm
doing great how you doing what do you
think well you know I think it could be
something like either Josh was sort of
teetering on the brink of losing his
sobriety or maybe he did something you
know had a little bit of a setback on
his own without without testing positive
for it where you know he opened up to
his caregivers and his medical team
about this or something like that it's
my understanding that he really hasn't
failed a test per se but for some reason
the medical director and his medical
team felt that it was time for him to go
back take a timeout and work on his
recovery
I believe he's either in inpatient rehab
or outpatient rehab right now but
whatever the case may be it was time for
him to try to get back on track so that
he doesn't fall through again and and
let's hope this Mary Kay because you
know the offseason can be long with with
without the the rigors or structure of
an NFL season perhaps that's a that's a
situation that can work against somebody
in Josh Gordon situations so perhaps him
getting in to camp and getting ready
when he's ready that that will be
helpful is that is that part of the
conversation that you're hearing in
Cleveland yeah I think so I think the
thing to remember with Josh Gordon is
that he's admitted to some serious drug
addiction over the past number of years
going on way back really to like middle
school in high school and what about
just talking about marijuana we're not
just talking about alcohol we're talking
about some pretty heavy drugs opiates
and codeine and different things like
that
and if you remember he said before this
the start of last season when he was
reinstated but it never played a game
sober both
last year so that's a lot to try to
overcome especially for a young person
who is surrounded by all kinds of
temptation so I think he found himself
in a place where he knew he was on a
little bit of shaky ground and again I
don't know how that manifested but he
was here in Berea he was working out
here a ton when he would see guys all
over the country Josh was right here in
Berea trying to stay close to his
counselors and his therapists and it was
only recently within the last month that
he left Berea and when I believe he's
back in in Gainesville or somewhere near
the University of Florida and within the
last month he decided to you know to
take this time out and go do what he
needed to do which i think is great and
I think real quick the other thing is
this to me represents a paradigm shift
in the NFL sort of from punishment to
rehab I mean they really have been
taking great pains to try to get Josh
Gordon back on the right track and not
continually punish him for for what
everyone seems to realize is an illness
now Mary Kay Cabot of The Plain Dealer
cleveland.com
joining me here on the show what do you
think this does this affect a
quarterback race at all I mean is there
really a race what can you tell me about
that story as that develops with
training camp opening in two days
Mary Kay well you know the narrative
heading into this camp is that Tyrod
Taylor is the starter and at this point
I don't really believe that that Baker
Mayfield will be given a fair shot to
really go out and win that starting job
and you can kind of control these
quarterback situations the way that you
want them to go I mean if they don't
give Baker Mayfield a lot of work with
the first team he's not going to be able
to beat out tie-rod Kayla so if they
genuinely don't want him to start on
opening day and I don't believe they do
then they will give Tyrod Taylor the
majority of the first team work and
Baker will just come up that learning
curve with the second team guys and then
you know and maybe hope to be the number
two guys during the season I believe
that that's the narrative having it why
don't they want him starting the season
walk me through the mindset there you
know what I think because Hugh Jackson
the last two years letting a rookie
learn on the job last year Deshawn
Kaiser he really had no choice but to
start - Sean Kaiser because they didn't
have anybody else
they had captain Hogan and Cody Kessler
on the roster
so he had to start - Sean Kaiser last
year this year he has a choice and the
year before that by default because of
injuries he had to start Cody Kessler
for eight games and he went on a tree
you're looking at Owen eight and Owen 15
with rookie starters over the last two
years he does not want to do that
anymore to himself to the fans for the
veterans on the team they want to win
some football games Tyrod Taylor has
experience he's gone to the playoffs and
I just think that they want to give
Baker that time it would be hard to
start him and then just yank him out of
there and go to tie rod after three or
four games so then what you don't mind
me I don't mean to I'm not laughs I mean
out laughing at I mean I mean it makes
total sense alright when you've won one
game over two years it is it is a
numbing experience and you've got to
start winning games but Baker Mayfield
is the Heisman Trophy winner you draft
him number one overall if he has the
ability to right now win a job and win
games in the NFL and be that guy and you
go through whatever growing pains you
need to go through better have him now
than you've been two years from now when
you find out that he's not the guy after
you you come up with what a couple of
Fugazi seasons of nine wins ten wins
without with a quarterback that you
don't plan to have a future with Mary
Kay yeah that one is the head scratcher
here no condition at the spot you know
what I understand exactly what you're
saying but I think when they work out
there what they see is a young
quarterback who really needs to learn
the pro game a little bit more before
they throw him out there now some guys
are a little bit more than more ready
than others at this point I mean Carson
Wentz they determined that you know
determined that he was ready to go I
think it's hurt because he had come out
of a pro NFL style system he was he was
used to parking out those plays he was
used to you know having to do all the
things that had to do play under center
and all of that Baker still has to
a lot of that kind of stuff and I I just
don't think that they feel that he's
going to be ready to do that you know in
a little bit over a month so I think for
them they're just going to take their
time even Todd Haley said at mini camp
that he has a long way to go now if you
didn't have a long way to go sure throw
them out there let him compete but I
think what they're seeing with with
their eyes is that he needs some time
they're not hoping he grows 2 or 3
inches in the time they have to wait
right then they're hoping that are they
America well if he did he'd be one inch
taller than Tyrod Taylor so I really
don't think that I don't think that's
the case I mean they believe in him
they're excited about him but they they
want to get it right and they don't want
to throw him out there before he's ready
and you know perhaps even damage his
confidence or whatever the case may be
it's impossible you can't damage that
kids confidence Mary Kay well you know
what if you remember back I mean Johnny
Manziel was a Heisman Trophy winner
Johnny Manziel was a first-round pick
and it's a two totally different things
here with a tremendous track record of
winning of laxity of playmaking and all
those sorts of things but you know it's
it this is time to put on your big-boy
pants when you're up here in the NFL all
right Mary Kay thanks for the time and I
pretty so is there I mean well at what
point do we or the Browns check back in
I mean at what point what what's the
timeframe if there is because it sounds
like this is one of those things that
there really can't be a time frame my
gosh Gordon Mary Kay well when I talked
to the NFL today spokesman Brian
McCarthy he said there is no timetable
and I have tried to press him a number
of times today on you know where is this
going what is this all about Josh sounds
optimistic you know you're telling me
there's no timetable and and basically
you know he has emphasized you know that
right now there there is no timeframe
they have to see how things go with what
Josh is doing right now and it's my
understanding like I said that but he is
in some kind of a treatment program and
and it's going to be up to the medical
team and the counselors to say you know
we think we can put it back on to a
football team and all the pressures that
come with it Mary Kay thanks for the
time
you uh you joining us thank you you got
us Mary cake habit of the Plain Dealer
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience